she was just the happiest little girl
all the time
Lucy
she was full of light
and
happiness and everyone that matter was
lit up by her
today would have been Lisi salisbury's
sixth birthday
but three weeks ago she lost her life
after a fire broke out at the family's
home in pembrokeshire
her mother Tara reached out to Sky News
to pay tribute to her daughter and talk
about what happened that day
we met at least his favorite Beach
Abby and Lisi had decided that they were
going to have a sister's sleepover as
they did very often
Abby tucked her into bed for the night
put some Telly on and went downstairs to
make her some brioche in the oven just
to warm them up for
the fire alarm was so sensitive in our
house that even if you just put a piece
of toast in the toaster it would go off
you know no burning needed it would just
go off for everything and because of
elise's autism
she couldn't stand loud noises it really
upset her and as usual the alarm went
off after about five minutes of being
downstairs Abby being downstairs they
leapt out of bed ran downstairs and
started pushing on the button to try and
get it to turn off
before it could upsetly see too much
but this time no matter how many times I
pushed the button the alarm wouldn't
turn off
and I said to Abby have you burned
something and she said no no it's
nothing burning
lisy started really screaming upstairs
like really screaming Abby ran up the
stairs by the time she got to the top of
the stairs she screamed oh my God the
room is on fire
and I turned my head to the staircase
and there was smoke coming down the
stairs and I just thought oh my God
Tara and her partner Josh ran upstairs
but the fire had taken hold
we didn't have any buckets or anything
to hand upstairs
and listen they thought if I run into
the bathroom and I soak a load of bath
towels in cold water I can wrap myself
up and I can run in and I can grab her
and I went to LEAP forwards and he
grabbed me and he said no way and he
took one of the towels and he threw it
in and it literally it burst it was
soaked but it burst into flames the
minute it hit the floor there was no
protection from it whatsoever the couple
and her two other daughters managed to
escape the house and trust their pajamas
with no possessions the community has
rallied raising around twenty thousand
pounds so far
what do you want to to do this interview
well why do you want to speak at this
point I just wanted to tell people what
happened
that night
yeah that helps you
the process of yeah it does with the
with the process of grieving and such is
letting people know what happened and
mostly to say thank you for all the
generosity
the cause of the fire isn't known and a
police investigation is underway
officers are not treating it as
suspicious
fatara it is a time of unimaginable pain
but places like this beach hold her
dearest memories
we would come down so that she could
play in the sea she just she loved being
in the water
all she wanted to do was be out in the
city
and I will miss her
so much
and that little tiny smile
Dan Whitehead Sky News at popit Sands
Beach in cardigan